hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
traten will ich habe heute ein leckeres
amerikaner rezept für euch und zwar
dachte ich mir mache ich die jetzt noch
mal ich hatte nämlich irgendwann schon
mal ein rezept gemacht aber ich habe sie
jetzt etwas verbessert und ich finde sie
passen einfach jetzt gut zur
faschingszeit also zumindest macht bei
uns hier fasching in anderen gebieten in
deutschland wahrscheinlich karneval oder
was gibt es noch
der fasching karneval sensor die zwei
gängigsten und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich weiß nicht wieso man das
gepäck amerikaner nennt das habe ich
mich jetzt gefragt bevor ich hier die
zutaten gerichtet habe da gibt's
natürlich verschiedene theorien dazu die
erzähle ich euch gleich noch aber ich
zeige euch erstmal die zutaten für den
rührteig denn es ist ein ganz normaler
basis rührteig aus dem das gebäck
hergestellt wird
also ich brauche dafür 100 gramm butter
die ist richtig schön zimmer waren die
habe ich gestern abend schon
rausgestellt eine prise salz 100 gramm
zucker zweier die sind auch zimmer warm
ich habe hier etwas von meinem
vanilleschoten extrakt das ist jetzt
fast leer aber für heute reicht noch ihr
könnt aber auch vanillezucker nehmen
ich habe 250 gramm mehl 50 g
speisestärke eine packung backpulver und
etwa 5 esslöffel milch und da ist
einfach ganz wichtig dass die zutaten
alle zimmer waren sind damit wir gleich
eine homogene masse haben
ich mache das ganze jetzt in einer
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt auch ganz
gern ein kontrollgerät nehmen und gibt
jetzt zuerst die butter in die schüssel
rein da kommt die prise salz mir dazu
einfach so ein bisschen nicht zu viel
und auch der zucker und jetzt wird das
ganze richtig cremig gerührt so etwa 23
minuten
und jetzt gebe ich hier meine vanille
mit dazu gab es ein paar tropfen es
reicht schon
und die zwei eier gebe ich nach und nach
dazu und verrührt es einfach noch mal
kurz
und jetzt gebe ich mein backpulver zum
mehl dazu damit einfach nicht klumpt und
verrührt es ganz kurz
damit sich so ein bisschen verteilen
kann
und jetzt kommen die restlichen zutaten
einfach mit dazu
die milch gebe ich jetzt nach und nach
halt und jetzt wird es wirklich nur ganz
kurz verrührt bis alles eben schön
homogen ist
das ganze schützen ziemlich feste
rührteig also das sieht man jetzt auch
hier aber das ist auch ganz wichtig so
denn die amerikaner sollen nicht
verlaufen sondern die so schön in form
bleiben
jetzt gibt es zwei verschiedene methoden
um das ganze auf dem backblech zu
bringen
entweder nimmt ihr euch einen
spritzbeutel und füllt die masse ein und
spritzt sie aufs blech so hatte ich
letztes mal schon gemacht oder ihr nehmt
euch einfach so einen ice portionierer
jetstar verschiedene größen einmal
mittel einmal groß ich nehme jetzt aber
den großen und stelle ich mir das jetzt
hier einfach vom teig ab und setze hier
auf mein backblech und da müsste jetzt
genug platz dazwischen lassen weil ihr
noch auseinander laufen
so habt ihr einfach immer optimal die
perfekte größe vor allen dingen werden
alle gleichmäßig kurs
und wird es dann soweit habt nehmt ihr
euch einfach so ein bisschen wasser und
befeuchtet eure hände denn dann werden
die amerikaner noch ein bisserl
geglättet denn ansonsten haben sie nicht
so eine schöne oberfläche und ich
drückte auch so ein bisschen flacher
wenn euch übrigens der teig zu fest ist
gibt einfach ein bisserl - dazu dass er
darf jetzt auch nicht zu arg fest ein
und so können das einfach noch ein
bisschen in form drücken und so werden
die amerikaner jetzt gebacken im ofen
bei ober und unterhitze bei etwa 200 bis
210 grad müsst ihr einfach abstimmen wie
heißer ofen wird
und da wollten sie für ungefähr sieben
bis zehn minuten gebacken schaut auf
jeden fall dass sie nicht zu trocken
werden also nicht zu dunkel werden
denn je länger sie im ofen sind und so
trockener werden sind und sobald sie
abgekühlt sind sehen wir uns gleich
wieder meine amerikaner sind jetzt
gebacken und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier auf einem
abkühlen lassen und ihr könnt ihr doch
sehen manche sind es richtig schön rund
und perfekt aber auch bei mir ist es so
dass man amerikaner nichts wird so wie
hier zum beispiel ist zwar vorher
irgendwie passiert als ich die früher so
mit dem spritzbeutel gemacht habe aber
es geht es ist absolut nicht schlimm den
kammern trotzdem essen er schmeckt
trotzdem sehr lecker und die anderen
sind einfach richtig schön und und sogar
beim bäcker werden sie sowieso nie also
so richtig perfekt dass ich alles
maschinell hergestellt und wir machen
alles selber und ich möchte meine jetzt
einmal mit schokolade überziehen also
mit kuvertüre besser gesagt ich hab dazu
jetzt hier schon zartbitter kuvertüre
fein gehackt das sind jetzt 150 gramm
und ich möchte auch einen teil mit einer
zitrone puderzucker klausur machen
deswegen habe ich hier eine zitrone und
habe auch 200 gramm puderzucker und ich
werde jetzt die kuvertüre in einer
küchenmaschine temperieren auf 30 grad
ihr könnt es aber auch ganz gern über
dem wasserbad über dem also in einem
topf machen aber dabei dann einfach
nicht das wasser kochen lassen und den
topf auch nicht auf dem herd lassen
sondern wasser abkochen und dann das
wasserbad machen die hitze reicht auf
jeden fall
ich lasse es jetzt hier einfach so
rühren und wird dann gleich in der
zwischenzeit in zuckerguss vorbereiten
jetzt kann ich mir meine zitrone nehmen
und macht den zuckerguss und ich mag es
ganz gern mit zitrone weiß dann einfach
etwas frischer schmeckt um so wissel
säuerlich aber ihr könnt auch gern wenn
ihr das nicht wollt einfach wasser
nehmen und die zitrone gebe ich jetzt
hier mit dazu erstmal nicht so viel weil
der zucker schlug darf jetzt nicht zu
dick werden eher nicht so flüssig werden
aber ich brauche hier noch ermitteln
also drei esslöffel lüftens ungefähr
sein
der zuckerguss hat jetzt etwas ohne
konsistenz also es relativ dickflüssig
und ich werde damit einen teil der
berliner und ich würde sagen der
amerikaner überziehen
aber ich nehme ein bisschen zuckerguss
weg damit ich gleich den zuckerguss noch
einfärben kann aber es kann nicht gleich
im anschluss machen während die trocken
deswegen fange ich jetzt einfach mal mit
denen an und nehme jetzt einfach immer
einen amerikaner und etwas vom
zuckerguss und streicht es mit so einer
kleinen palette aus könnte auch ein
kleines messer nehmen und aus den weißen
werde ich jetzt gleich ein paar clowns
machen und deswegen muss ich auch ein
bisschen zucker teig zuckerguss und
werben
aber die last jetzt erstmal so trocknen
jetzt kann ich die ganz kurz weg stellen
damit sie trocknen und ich sie dann
später gleich als clown gesicht
dekorieren kann und ihm derzeit mache
ich schon mal meine dunklen amerikaner
und nehme mir hierfür einfach meint
robert führe die habe ich jetzt
natürlich hier drin also die ist richtig
schön temperiert jetzt auch und das ist
auch hier ganz wichtig damit die
einfachen schönen glanz hat und nicht
ebenso ein grauschleier bekommt und da
ist genauso dann nehmt ihr euch einfach
bisschen kuvertüre dedizierten die mitte
und ich mag halt ganz ganz bitter
kuvertüre aber ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel vollmilch nehmen und dann wird
es auch mit seiner palette kurz
verstrichen
und bei denen ist so die dekore ich
jetzt mit ein paar bunten zucker
streuseln da gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene auch im supermarkt zum
beispiel und die gebe ich hier einfach
drüber weil das sieht jetzt aus wie so
viel konfetti auf dem amerikaner drauf
und das passt doch richtig gut zu
fasching und die lasse ich dann einfach
hier komplett austrocknen
die hellen amerikaner sind jetzt
getrocknet und jetzt kann ich den
restlichen zuckerguss einfach einfärben
und dafür nehme ich hier meine passten
farben des teams die von der ovag die
gibt es auch in jedem supermarkt zu
kaufen
und ich nehme da jetzt einmal schwarz
rot und grün damit ich einen clown
machen kann und deswegen teile ich mir
hier jetzt den restlichen zuckerguss
noch auf falls euch der zuckerguss nicht
gereicht hat müsst ihr noch mal welche
neben anrühren und ich habe nochmal
bisschen zitrone rein damit ein bisschen
flüssiger wird und ich das ganze eben
besser spritzen kann braucht man auch
noch eine ganz kleine menge
ich beginne jetzt einfach mit der roten
farbe da brauche ich jetzt etwas weniger
nie etwas mehr von schwarz brauch ich
weniger und gebt einfach so ein bisschen
hier dazu das wird dann kurz verrührt
ich gebe da noch ein bisschen dazu damit
ein richtiges knallrot wird für die nase
so gefällt mir richtig gut kann etwas
zur seite stellen
grün brauche ich jetzt etwas mehr weil
die haare des clowns grün werden soll
sodass eine richtig schöne knallige
farbe die nehme ich auch so und jetzt
noch ein bisschen spaß und ich sehe dass
ich davon eigentlich gar nicht so viel
farbe brauchen weil die einfach so
pastörs sind und einfach sehr hoch
konzentriert sind
schaut mal wie schön es ist schwarz
aussieht und dafür nehme ich mir zu
kleine spritzbeutel ihr könnt da zum
beispiel auch so kleine gefrierbeutel
nehmen oder es geht dir diese
süßigkeiten typen die man bekommt die
könnte auch dafür benutzten stelle ich
mir einen glas und fülle mir da jetzt
einfach die farben rein
und hinten verschließe ich die tüte
einfach mitten und knüpfen damit der
nächste aufgeht
für den clown habe ich jetzt hier noch
so ein paar zucker augen die sind es war
und diesen übrigens auch von deco back
und gibt es auch in jedem supermarkt
könnte da mal schauen und die benutze
ich jetzt um einfach damit einfacher
geht mit dem clown gesicht jetzt braucht
ihr einfach für jedes clown gesichts bei
augen wie lege ich mir jetzt hier schon
mal her und mohammed zuerst die nase mit
dem rot und werdet da einfach so eine
kleine spitze abschneiden und jetzt
zuerst mal die nase vom clown
aufzeichnen einfach so ein bisschen in
die mitte auch nicht so groß weil es
sich nicht rudolph das rentier sondern
soll ja ein clown sein
das könnt ihr euch am besten ins glas
zurückstellen am tropf bisher nicht
runter und dann können dann mit hilfe
eines zahnstochers einfach die nase noch
ein bisschen formen
also ich hab mir das jetzt hier mit
kreisenden bewegungen noch ein bisschen
hier rechts in form dann nehme ich meine
zucker augen die klebe ich einfach mit
ein bisschen zucker kleber an also mit
bisserl zuckerguss meinig
kommt hier so ein bisschen von dem rest
nehmen und dann einfach ankleben
so
und dekorieren wird es einfach mit dem
rest noch schulen
und dann einfach mit dem grünen die
haare
und dann haben wir unseren kurs halligan
clown als ich bin klauser total große
nicht deswegen wir nochmal aber als sie
der ziemlich lustig aus und warum ich
die erweiterte korrekt kann ich euch
noch mal wegen den theorien dass kurz
erzählen und zwar habe ich ja gedruckt
wieso die amerikaner amerikaner heißen
und habe gesagt es gibt verschiedene
theorien und zwar ist die erste theorie
dass details also die amerikanischen
soldaten während dem weltkrieg hier
waren in deutschland und da einen
amerikanischen cache backen wolken aber
da die zutaten nicht gefunden haben und
so haben sie den amerikanischen oder den
amerikaner eben kreiert und die zweite
theorie war es so roth dass die black
and white cookies aus amerika in den 50
jahren nach deutschland kamen und dann
die deutschen aber black and white
cookies nicht aussprechen konnten
und daneben amerikaner dazu gesagt haben
also das war so das sind so die zwei
theorien
aber ich weiß natürlich nicht welche
davon stimmt und ob sie überhaupt
stimmen kann ich einfach mein amerikaner
weg essen
da war für die deko was zwar weko habe
ich habe gerade einfach nur ja das war
auch der schöne so schöne sich heute zum
essen laufende war schon angewiesen
also ich bin hier umgeben von leuten aus
von kameraleuten murat und kariya
einfach die ganze meine deko weg ist ein
echt unglaublich
mein gott
zum glück habe ich ein paar merkel
packen zum glück
okay ich bin mit den amerikanern fertig
und so sehen sie jetzt bei uns aus ich
finde die sind richtig schön vor allen
dingen auch so schön faschings tisch was
für ein special effekt also ich bin
total der faschingsmuffel aber ich nehme
natürlich gern als anlass um was zu
backen und auch zu kochen und sich sagen
wir wollen nicht zeigen
ich zeige euch einfach mal wieder
amerikaner innen aussieht also von der
konsistenz ok morath ist reicht von der
konsistenz her sind sie wirklich so
richtig sandig also wie vom bäcker wie
man das eben so kennt und ihr könnt mir
jetzt einfach mal sagen ob ihr zum
beispiel auch wie ich faschingsmuffel
seit und er zu hause bleibt oder ob ihr
auf achse geht und richtig mitfeiern und
vor allen dingen wie heißt bei uns moral
auf dem umzug mit ihm hat auch ein umzug
in samira dass er da gucken kann und
stützt
bei uns heißt helau aber ich weiß wo
anders heißt auch alle da kennt aber
schreiben wie es bei euch heißt da wo
ich herkomme heiß mond stück also sind
die neuen stoffe in dotternhausen
bei uns gibt's die schlumpf hier in
waghäusel die finde ich ehrlich sagt
netz so schön weil sie alles schwarz ins
sicht sind aber so richtig schönes
karneval gefällt mir auch und mein
rezept gibt es auch sallys - blog.de und
ich freue mich auf eure rückmeldungen
und wünsche euch allen noch einen ganz
schönen tag bis dann sei es einfach die
ganze zeit ein paar stangen zu - auf
meine soll stoffen in der luft schlange
mache das so an zwei anderen effekt